está acá elpresidente trump también
esperando estos resultados resultados
que han salido hace unos minutos en
arizona y en nevada en nevada
precisamente el candidato demócrata gana
20.000 votos más y lo que queda por
contar en ese estado es son los votos en
el condado de clark es de un condado que
según pronostican es de mayoría
demócrata algo que podría hacer que la
ventaja en nevada del candidato yo bailé
pues incremente o dar datos concretos en
georgia a pesar de como usted lo
mencionaba se va a ser un reconteo yo
bailé gana en este momento según ap por
mil 587 votos esto es un margen de
ganancia del 0 1 por ciento con el 99
por ciento de los votos contados en
pensilvania la ventaja de bailén es de 6
mil 737 votos un margen de ganancia de
0.1 por ciento a favor de bailén con el
95 por ciento contado en arizona la
ventaja de bailén es de 43 mil votos con
el 93 por ciento contado y en nevada
con el 92 por ciento contado según los
resultados que se acaban de publicar la
ventaja ya es de cerca de 22 mil votos
es de resaltar la respuesta que ha
tenido el presidente trump recientemente
sobre el caso de pensilvania en su
cuenta de 'twitter' dijo que pensilvania
se ha comportado de forma horrible y
pues que va a disputar estos resultados
y que espera que la corte suprema de
justicia de eeuu de mayoría y de corte
conservador se ocupe del tema sin
embargo a pesar de pues estas disputas
que sigue dando y que sigue diciendo que
va a ser el presidente tronco en estas
elecciones hace unos minutos la bicolor
su asesor económico salió a decir
públicamente que la transición de poder
en eeuu se haría de forma pacífica